hey guys it's Giga Kia wow it's uh sir
been a while since I talked to you guys
like this so I'm really not used to
vlogging I mean look at me I'm just one
guy sitting in my bedroom talking to a
camera but if you haven't noticed for
the past month I've been doing something
rather strange yes I've been uploading
it again and I know a bunch of you are
wondering why so I thought I'd update
you guys and what I've been doing this
entire time and we're a VIP so to give
you a brief rundown around two and a
half years ago I graduated from
University with an engineering degree
and I got a job I know
grown up [ __ ] and stuff right I got a
job as a technical project manager
working with a company that was
subcontracted to the BBC but it's kind
of easier just to say I worked for the
BBC because that's kind of what I did
all the time and I got this job round
about the time that I finished AVA
bridge 4.0 so if you look back to my
video uploading history go back to
average 4.0 and then look at all the
upload schedule up to a verage 4.0 you
can see that there is a huge dip in
productivity on my channel and that's
kind of the reason why I mean the only
time I would really have a lot of time
to work on videos is during the
Christmas holidays where would pump out
the anime in year whatever and the thing
is I'd always manage to get part one out
in time during the Christmas holidays
and then the holidays would end and I
would need to go back to my job and if
anyone has ever had a job and try to
make YouTube content at the same time
you'd know that balancing two things is
[ __ ] difficult as [ __ ] so that's why
there would always be a three-month
delay from part one being released to
part two being released and you know
sometimes I get the odd free time to
work in a video but the majority of the
time there was no time for me to work on
videos at all because you know
unfortunately that's for getting a job
and being an adult means so that's what
I've been doing for the past two years
really not six lighting as I want it to
be or want to say hey I've been doing
all this [ __ ] but no I've just been
working on a job that's basically been
xed so then you may ask why am I
suddenly uploading again and between you
and me after two years working and a
normal job not that I hated it or
anything
but I kind of got thinking you know what
am i really happy doing and I just
thought I really missed being active on
YouTube you know because I thought you
loved doing YouTube content I love
making videos for you guys I love
talking to you guys help most my friends
I have in real life and online our
friends that I met through YouTube I
mean friends who are either are the
content creators or just fans who are
Meza conventions and just hang out with
you know this is what I love doing and I
had so many ideas of projects I wanted
to do some more like stilly stuff like
animated minutes and some are bigger
more serious projects and it's just a
mixture of both and kind of dawned on me
that I would never be able to do the
things I wanted to do if I stayed in the
job so it was then that I made the
decision to quit my job and try pursuing
YouTube full-time you know even though I
might take a pay cut you know cuz my job
wasn't bad but I wanted to try doing
something that I really enjoyed doing
and seeing if I can make something out
of it so in preparation for this I saved
up enough money to support myself for
about six months to a year so that's the
time limits I've given myself to see if
I can make something out of this and if
I fail I fail you know I go off YouTube
again I go back to getting a normal job
and you know becoming a normal person in
society but at least I'd have the chance
to pursue something I fully enjoy and I
wouldn't have any regrets in that sense
so yeah that's the decision I came to
make and I hope you guys stick with me
through this journey I'm about to take
in my life now I'm sure this thing to
this a lot of you will be wondering why
do I just start a patreon since you know
unfortunately ad revenues they were near
high enough to support my extravagant
lifestyle of you know eating and paying
rent so I probably will eventually but
at the moment I hadn't figured out how I
want to do it yet and right now I just
want to focus on getting more content
out so that's where I've been in terms
of that update uh in terms of other
updates that have I'm actually gonna be
moving to America for the next three
months and in that time I'm gonna be
attending a sin and ax so if you guys
want a fan meetup at any of those cons
I'll be sure to set something up and uh
but you gonna try my hand at streaming a
bit so I've set up a twitch channel for
now at the moment I've only done League
of Legends but I do want to do much more
than just that on there and as always if
you want any other updates just follow
me on Twitter so uh yeah I think that's
it
the TLDR version is I had a job I quit
my job I'm going YouTube full-time for
at least six
two year I'm going to a sent an ax I
have a twitch follow me on Twitter I
love your seriously and I'll see you all
next time